Watch. By the way, in rabbitic Judaism,
where is it? Here,
they do not mention the name of Jesus
Christ. Let me give you a little
background. In rabbitic Judaism,
they do not mention the name Jesus
Christ. They'll say JC. Why? Because of
a passage that says, "You shall not
mention the names of their gods." I need
you to listen.
You should not mention the names of
their gods.
So they don't mention Jesus' name. They
say JC or they will curse him in Hebrew
saying Yeshu.
Yeshu. Yeshu is an acronym in Hebrew
meaning may his name and memory be
blotted out.
When you hear an Orthodox Jew say Yeshu,
he's insulting Jesus. Cuss him out.
say, "No, your rabbis are blow out there
in hell burning like dogs."
Okay?
When they say Yeshu, they're insulting
Jesus. It's an insult.
It's an insult
because the name of our Lord is Yeshua.
You didn't know that Yeshua is an
insult. Come on, guys. I mentioned in
the past here. Here we go.
Yeshua acronym. Here you go. here. Here
you go. She Google Yeshu is often
identified in Jewish specifically Tmuric
and medieval context as an acronym for
the Hebrew phrase shamro
which translates may his name and memory
be blotted out. It's right there man.
You can't see the screen. Just put Yeshu
acronym.
They are insulting, blaspheing Lord
Jesus when they call him Yeshu.
Okay.
Yeah. I'll tell you why it's ironic,
brother. Because they confirm what the
Bible says.
And so they will say JC, and I'll show
you how they're
>> the Christians evangelist.
>> The Christians evangelist. You stupid
Christian Zionists. You are disgracing
the Lord Jesus and shaming him and
weaponizing these dogs. Look
>> here in America, which almost all the
Christians evangelist here in America,
which almost all of them are
Republicans,
they probably all going to vote for
Trump and they are very pro-Israel. They
are the ones that thanks to them, United
States always been with Israel in last
few decades.
>> Did you hear it?
You are a disgrace. You Christian
Zionists, you insult the Lord Jesus
because you pervert the scriptures and
then you bend over backwards
and now they're laughing at you, mocking
you and your Lord and Savior Jesus
Christ. You see, he said it. It's the
evangelicals that have caused the United
States to support Israel.
If you take our Christianity out of the
picture, what United States has to do
with Israel? The only things they are
helping us is because of religion
reason.
>> I'm stopping at a key point so I don't
get flagged.
See?
See that? Okay.
But what a lot of Jews do not know is
that they're not doing it for us.
>> Aha. The gig is up. The cat is out of
the bag.
The Jews don't know. The Christians are
not doing it for us. They don't give a
damn about us. Now watch. They know the
script. Listen.
They are doing it only for themselves.
Make no mistake.
>> What?
>> They all believe
that once we will go back to the Holy
Land and JC Penny will show up. You see
the insult?
Do you see? Not only did he not call him
Jesus Christ, he goes, "J Penney is not
worse than Muslims.
Seriously.
Do you want you wonder why the old Sam
shows up once in a while?
Why the old Sam?"
Buddy, JC Penney is a department store.
I guess you're too young to remember J.
C. Penney.
Do you now blame me, son of his
right-hand others, for being nasty the
way I am?
All right.
JC Penney calls him
JC Penney. See that?
Not only JC JC Petty, look what he's
going to say.
>> To redeem the world, he will put us all
to be burned in hell. That's what they
believe. Cuz we never accepted him and
we won't accept him. So why they want to
help us to take over Israel
>> to win against the Arabs?
>> Why? Listen,
>> make sure the Jews go. Why they pay all
these organization that sponsor aliyah
to go up to Jerusalem? Why do they do
that? Listen of the people who made
aliyah it's Christian money.
>> Do you hear it?
Who sends the Jews to Jerusalem?
Look, listen.
>> Organization that sponsor aliyah. A lot
of the people who made aliyah, it's
Christian money. All their come from
them.
>> From them.
>> There are some reformed rabbis who have
connection with them. And they get
hundreds of millions of dollars donation
from them.
>> Do how much? Hundreds of millions of
dollars. Shame on you. You Christian
Zionists. You are a disgrace to the name
of the Lord Jesus Christ. You Bible
perverts. But listen,
Rabbi is from Anat from Texas.
Why they are so generous? Why are they
donating money to Israel? Why do they
care about Israel? The answer is because
they believe the Messiah would come.
They just have the wrong identity of the
Messiah. That's it.
They believe that it's actually JC. Then
>> JC JC.
Now watch the arrogance of this demon.
If I debate him, I'll bury him like the
Lord Jesus buried his
>> never watch my debate with the Christian
professor. They would watch it quickly.
They would dump all the Christian
symbols. You know where
>> because it would be so obvious that it's
>> where you see you know where. Now watch
this other clip how he mocks us.
No, but you know uh the Muslims are the
problem. Listen, brother. You're not pro
or anti-Israel. You're not pro
anti-Palestine.
You're anti-Rabbic Judaism. Anti-Islam,
anti-Muhammad.
Okay, get your facts straight.
Now watch this clip
right here. Another one. Same dude.
>> How can my
>> Look, look at this mockery.
>> Not be happy when I see millions of goim
bow down to one Jew tonight.
[snorts]
>> Look at that satanic filthy wicked smile
of this.
How can I not be happy when I see
millions of goim, meaning Gentiles,
bowing to one Jew, meaning Jesus, and
you're going to bow before his feet.
When they took their religion from the
Jews,
this foolish Christianity that they
invented, [music] they took some things
from Judaism and developed lots of
nonsense on top of it. But even their
religion came from the Jews.
>> Even their Messiah is a Jew that was
kicked out of Yeshiva.
Do you see it? Their their tradition is
Jesus was thrown out of Yeshiva
because he was a sorcerer.
So you're telling me
that you hate the Muslims or Muslim
terrorists
because their religion, but you ignore
and don't want to deal with what the
tomet says about Jesus. You're okay with
that? I'm going to show you something
else. Lord, help me remember. Now, watch
this. Let's finish this.
>> I'm still a Jew in Christmas Eve.
Tonight, it's becoming Yoshka's
birthday. Even though it's total
nonsense,
>> Yoshka's birthday. You see, Yoshk
doesn't even pronounce his name.
December 25th. They're talking about
December 25th
>> because they started Christmas 300 years
after Christianity started. They didn't
have Christmas. [music]
They don't have New Year's Eve. They
thought they don't have any holidays
after 300 years. They made up two
events. Nothing to do with him. But they
don't even know it. They think it's
really his birthday or whatever.
>> See the arrogance of this guy, the
arrogance of this guy.
>> He said to him, [music] "Tonight is my
happiest night of the year."
>> Say to the go and he looked at him said
why? He said it's our holiday. It's a
Christian holiday. Why it's your
happiest night of your year? He say,
"How can I not be happy when I see
millions of goim bow down to one Jew
tonight?" [laughter]
Look at that demonic
demonic laughter. Millions of go. Yeah.
Because he's not merely a Jew. He's the
God of Abraham and he's the one who to
hell and will damn you to like a pig if
you don't repent. You scum. Son of
Satan.
And you still want to tell me they're
the chosen people. Huh?
You still want to tell me they're the
chosen people? Lord, remind me what you
wanted me to cover. But nonetheless, you
see that?
You still want to tell me they're the
chosen people? Huh? Really? Chosen?
Chosen for what?
Don't bring in your zeal and love for
Israel into your Christian faith. The
Lord Jesus Christ is not pro-Israel
anti-Palestine. Jesus Christ our Lord is
pro- kingdom of God.
He's not Republican. He's not Democrat.
Dude, get over this nonsense. Now, with
that said, we'll get into the topic of
John 1. But I just wanted to mention
this.
And you know what's ironic? You want to
hear what's ironic? Do you know that in
the Quran there are verses that were
composed
to refute the Jewish slander of the Holy
Mother?
Did you know that?
In chapter 4 of the Quran, if you read
155 157, it's Muhammad's defense against
the assault on Mary by the Jews, saying
that Mary was an adulterous Do
you want me to give you the receipts?
You want me to prove it to you?
Here, let me show it to you. You want to
be shocked and I'll give you the taps.
The taps. All right. Here.
All right.
Here you go. Chapter 4, the Quran is
because of their breaking the covenant
and they're rejecting the ayat of Allah
and if they're killing the prophets
unjustly and they're saying, "Our hearts
are wrapped with coverings. We do not
understand what the messengers say. Nay,
Allah has set a seal upon their hearts
because of their disbelief. So they
believe not but a little and because of
their Jews disbelief and uttering
against me
a grave false charge that she has
committed illegal
and because of their boasting wea
right here man the Quran is rebuking
them for insulting Mary and Jesus. Now,
let's go to the taps 4156, right? Okay.
Do you guys know this or no?
Here you go.
So, you hate Islam justifiably so, but
you don't hate the tom, which is worse,
and you got apologist for the tomah to
try to explain away the tom and its
statements,
right?
Really,
here you go. 156.
Why did this passage why was it composed
not come down because it came down from
Satan
and for this belief
a second time in Jesus
right and they're uttering against Mary
a tre tremendous calimny when they
accused her of fornication do you see it
even at the time of Muhammad
the Jews were saying Mary was an
adulteress
Mary was an adulteress.
They were saying it gladly boastfully to
the Muslims saying, "Wait, you want us
to believe Jesus and who's defending her
honor? The Quran.